YUFEI ZHAO: All
right, today we're
going to start a new topic
an additive combinatorics.
And this is a
fairly central topic
having to do with the
structure of set addition.
So the main players
that we're going
to be seeing in this
chapter have to do with,
if you start with a subset
of some obedient group
under addition--
not necessarily finite.
So the obedient
group that I'm going
to keep in mind, the ones
that will come up generally
are integers, z mod n or
the finite field model.
We're going to be looking at
objects such as a sum set, so
a plus b, meaning the set of
elements that can be written
as a sum, where you
take one element
from a and another from b.
Likewise, you can also have
a minus b defined similarly,
now taking a minus b.
We can iterate this operation.
So kA, so 2A, 3A,
4A, for instance,
means I add A to
itself k times, not
to be confused with a dilation,
which we'll denote by k dot A.
So this is notation for
multiplying every element of A
by the number k.
So given a subset of integers
I can do these operations
to the set.
And I want to ask, how
does the size of the set
change when I do
these operations?
For example, what is the
largest or the smallest?
So how large or small can A plus
A be for a given set size, A?
So if I allow you
to use 10 elements,
how can you make A plus
A as big as possible?
And how can you make it
as small as possible?
So this is not a hard question.
How can you make it
as big as possible?
So what's the
maximum size A plus A
can be as a function of A?
Well, I'm looking
at pairwise sums,
so if there are no collisions
between different pairwise
sums, this is as
large as possible.
And then it's not hard to see
that the maximum possible is
the size of A plus 1, choose 2.
So since at most,
this many pairs
and space possible if
all sums are distinct.
So for example, in integers,
you can take 1, 2, 2 squared,
and so on.
So that will give you the span.
The minimum possible
is also not too hard.
We're allowed to work in
a general obedient group.
So in that case, the minimum
could be just the size of A.
The size is always at
least the size of A.
And this is tight
if A is a subgroup.
If you have a subgroup, then
it's closed under addition.
So the set does not
expand under addition.
In the integers, you don't
have any finite subgroups.
So if I give you k integers,
what's the smallest,
the sum set can be?
AUDIENCE: 2k minus 1.
YUFEI ZHAO: 2k minus 1, right?
So the example is when you
have an arithmetic progression.
So in integers, the
minimum is 2k minus 1.
And it's achieved for an
arithmetic progression.
So let me just give you the
one-line proof why you always
have at least this
many elements,
is if A has elements
sorted like this,
then the following elements
are distinct in the sum set.
So you start with
A plus A. And then
you move A1 plus A2, A1 plus
A3, and so on, to A1 plus Ak.
And then you move the
first element forward.
OK, so here you already see
2k minus 1 distinct elements
in A plus A.
OK, so these are
fairly simple examples,
fairly simple questions.
So now let's get to some more
interesting questions, which
is, what can you say
about a set if you know
that it has small doubling?
If it doesn't
expand by very much,
what can you tell
me about the set?
And for that, let me define the
notion of a doubling constant.
So the doubling
constant of A is defined
to be the number
which we often denote
by k, the number obtained by
dividing the size of A plus A
by the size of A. And we
would like to understand--
and this is the
main question that's
addressed in the
upcoming lectures is,
what is the structure of a set
with bounded doubling constant?
So for instance,
think of k as fixed.
Let's say k is 100.
If you know a set has doubling
constant, at most, 100,
what can you tell me about
the structure of the set?
So that's the main question.
Let me show you in a second
a few examples of sets
the have bounded
doubling constant.
So that's easy to check
that those examples indeed
have bounded doubling constant.
And what this
question amounts to
is what is often known
as an inverse question.
So it's an inverse
problem that asks
you to describe in reverse--
so it's easy to check
in the upcoming examples
that all of those examples
have bounded doubling constant.
And what we want to
say is, in reverse,
that if a set has bounded
doubling constant,
then it must in some sense
look like one of our examples.
It's the harder
inverse question.
OK, so let me give you
some examples of sets
with small doubling constant.
One example we
already saw earlier
is that if you have an
arithmetic progression.
If you have an
arithmetic progression,
then the size of
A plus A is always
2 times the size of A minus 1.
So the doubling constantly
is always, at most, 2.
That's pretty small.
That's as small as you can get
in arithmetic progressions is
in the integers.
But if you start with an
arithmetic progression
and now I take just a
subset of the elements
of this progression,
so if I take AP,
and if I cross out a few
elements, just a small number
of elements from this
progression, or even
cross out most, but
keeping a constant fraction
of elements still
remaining, I claim
that's still a pretty good set.
So if A can be
embedded inside an AP
such that the AP has size
no more a constant factor
and more than that of A,
then the size of A plus A is,
at most--
so we bound it by the size of P
plus P, which is, at most, 2P.
So the doubling constant
of A is, at most, 2C.
So if you have a set which is
at least 1/10 fraction of an AP,
then you are doubling
constant at most, 20, bounded.
So this is another
class of examples.
So it's kind of a
modification, some alteration
of the arithmetic progression.
Another more substantial
generalization of APs
is that of a two-dimensional
arithmetic progression.
So you think of an
arithmetic progression
as equally spaced
points on a line.
But you can extend this
in multiple dimensions,
so like a grid.
So this is a two-dimensional
arithmetic progression,
but I still want to work
inside the integers.
So what we are going to
do is project this picture
onto the integers.
So that's a two-dimensional
arithmetic progression.
And specifically, we
have a set of the form,
so x0 is the starting
point, plus l1 of x1--
l1 times x1, and l2
2 times x2, where
the little l's are
integers, non-negative
integers up to big L.
So that's a two-dimensional
arithmetic progression.
So the picture that you can have
in mind is, on the number line,
we can get, write
down first an AP
and then a few more
points like that so
that you can have a
two-dimensional arithmetic
progression.
We say that this set, this
two-dimensional arithmetic
progression is proper if
all terms are distinct.
And if that's the case,
then I can write A plus A
in a very similar format.
So A plus A contains elements
still of the same form,
but now the indices
go up to 2L minus 1.
So you see that A plus A
has size, at most, 4 times
the original set, A. Also easy
to see from this blue picture
up there--
you expand that grid.
It goes to, at most,
4 times the size.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
question is, should it be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: 2x0?
YUFEI ZHAO: What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: 2x0 plus l1 x0 plus 1?
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah, thank
you, so 2x0, thank you.
Yeah, 2x0, great.
OK, so that's the size.
And of course, you can
generalize this example
of a fairly straightforward
way to d dimensional arithmetic
progressions.
And we call those
things generalized
arithmetic progressions.
So a Generalized
Arithmetic Progression,
which we will abbreviate
by the letters GAP,
is a set of numbers
of the form as above,
except now you have d different
directions and indices,
are also straightforward
generalizations
of what was earlier.
So this is the notion of
a generalized arithmetic
progression.
So think about projection
of a d dimensional grid
onto the integers.
And for GAPs, we
say that it's proper
if all the terms are distinct.
We call d the
dimension of the GAP.
And for a GAP, whether
it's proper or not,
we call the size to be the
product of the lengths.
And this is potentially larger.
So this is larger than the
number of distinct elements
if it's not proper.
So when I refer to
the size of a GAP--
so I view the GAP more
than just as a set,
but also with the data
of the initial point
and the directions.
If I talk about the
size, I'm always
referring to this
quantity over here.
Great.
So you see, if you take a GAP
or a fraction of a GAP, then,
as with earlier examples,
you have small doubling.
So if P is a proper
GAP, of dimension d,
then P plus P is,
at most, 2 raised
to power d times the size
of P. And furthermore,
if A is an arbitrary subset of
P and such that A has size--
such that the GAP
has size, at most,
a constant fraction
bigger than that of A,
then A has small
doubling as well.
So all of these are
examples of constructions
of sets where, for some
fixed constant, the doubling
constant, we can
find a family of sets
with doubling constant
bounded by that number.
And the natural question though
is, are these all the examples?
So have we missed
some important family
of constructions not covered
by any of these examples?
And so that's the kind
of inverse question
I was referring to earlier.
So all of these examples,
easy to check that they indeed
have small doubling constant.
Can you go in reverse?
So can you ask the
inverse question,
if a set has small
doubling constant,
must it look like, in some
sense, one of these sets?
It turns out this is not
such an easy problem.
And there is a central result
in additive combinatorics known
as Freiman's theorem which
gives a positive answer
to that question.
So Freiman's theorem is now
considered a central result
in additive combinatorics.
And it completely
describes, in some sense,
the sets that have
small doubling.
And let me write
down the statement.
So if A is a subset of Z
and has bounded doubling,
then A is contained in a GAP
of bounded dimension and size
bounded by some constant
times the size of the set.
This is a really
important result
in additive combinatorics.
The title of this chapter,
"Structure of Set Addition,"
Freiman's theorem tells us
something about the structure
of a set with small doubling.
The next few lecturers
are going to be occupied
with proving this theorem.
So this theorem will have--
its proof is involved and
probably the most involved
proof that we have
in this course.
And the proof will take
the next several lectures.
And we'll see a lot of
different ingredients,
a lot of really nice tools.
Fourier analysis will
come up at some point,
but also other tools like the
geometry of numbers and also
some more classical additive
combinatorics ideas.
But before starting
on a proof, I
want to offer a few remarks
and historical remarks to just
give you some more context
about Freiman's theorem,
but first, a few
mathematical comments.
In this conclusions
of Freiman's theorem,
I didn't mention properness.
And that's mostly a
matter of convenience.
So you can, in fact, make
the conclusion proper
as well at the cost of
increasing the number somewhat,
but still constants
depending only on k--
can guarantee
properness as well.
So there is an extra step
involved which we'll not cover,
because it's not
entirely trivial,
but it's also not too hard.
Freiman's original proof,
so it's named after Freiman.
So he proved that in the '60s.
But at that time, the proof
was considered rather obscure.
It actually did not get the
attention and the recognition
that it deserved
until much later.
So this was kind of a forgotten
result, a forgotten proof
for a very long time until
quite a bit later when Ruzsa--
Ruzsa's name will come up
many times in this chapter.
Ruzsa came and gave a different
proof of Freiman's theorem,
and significantly
cleaned up the proof,
and offered many new ideas.
So much of what we'll
see today are results
that we now attribute to Ruzsa.
And theorem sometimes
is also called
the Freiman-Ruzsa theorem.
But this result was
really brought into--
brought as a highlight
of additive combinatorics
in the work of Gowers
when he proved,
that gave his new proof
of Szemerédi's theorem,
giving much better bounds.
So he had to use quite a bit of
serious additive combinatorics.
And many of the ideas that
went into Gowers' proof
of Szemerédi's theorem came
from this line of work,
Freiman and Ruzsa.
So and their work was, again,
brought into prominence
as a result of Gowers'
Fields-Medal-winning work
on Szemerédi's theorem.
So this is some of the history.
And now Freiman's
theorem is considered
a central result in the area.
You can see, it's
a beautiful result.
And it's also quite
a deep result.
Let me mention a few
things about bounds.
So what do we know about
this d of k and f of k?
But first, an example--
so if the set A is dissociated
in the sense of having
no arithmetic structure,
no coincidental sums
colliding, so for example,
if a of this form,
then you see that--
also and we saw the size of A
plus A, so A plus 1 choose 2.
So in this case, the
doubling constant
is the size of A plus 1
divided by 2, so roughly
on the same order
as the size of A.
But what do you need to
take in Freiman's theorem
for d and for f?
So how can I embed this A
in generalized arithmetic
progression?
See, there is not a
great way to do it.
So I want to keep
the size small.
There is not a
great way to do it.
So one way to do it is
to use one direction
for each of these elements.
So contained in GAP--
now of course, there
is always a trade
off between dimension and size.
But usually, not a great--
I mean, it's not such
an important trade off.
So but certainly it's
contained in the GAP
of dimension size of
A minus 1 and size
2 to the size of A minus 1,
by thinking about A as a cube.
And so you convince yourself
that you basically cannot do
much better.
So the best possible bound
that we can hope to prove
is of the form d being,
at most, linear in k,
and f being, at most,
exponential in k.
So you see already,
the bounds, that you
have to lose some things.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why can't we
just make the dimension 1
and just let our arithmetic
progression be 1 through 2
to the sine of A minus 1?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, great, so
that's a great question.
So why can't we just
make dimension 1
and have the entire
thing be as part
of a single linear
arithmetic progression?
So you can do that, but then
I can cook up other examples
where I blow up this cube.
So I ask you to think
about how to do that.
So you can try to
blow up this cube
so that you really
do need the dimension
to not be constant, so exercise.
So the best result is
not quite this claim.
So this is still open.
So the best result so far is
due to Tom Sanders, whose name
came up earlier, as he has
basically the best bound
on Roth's theorem.
And you know, many
of these results
are all related to each other.
So Sanders has-- so he showed
that Freiman's theorem is
true with d being,
so basically k,
but you lose a poly log factor.
I think the big O is maybe
3, or 4, something like that,
so not substantial.
And then f of k is also
basically exponential,
but you lose a poly log
factor in the exponent.
Just a minor note about
how to read this notation--
so I mean, it's written
slightly sloppily as log k
raised to big O of 1.
You should think k as
constant, but somewhat big,
because if k were 2,
this notation actually
doesn't make sense.
So just think of
chaos, as at least 3
when you read that notation.
All right, so we will
prove Freiman's theorem.
So this bound will
show a worse bound.
It actually will be basically
exponentially worse,
but it will be a constant.
So it will be just
a function of k.
And that will take us the
next several lectures.
So we'll begin by developing
some tools that are,
I think, of interest
individually.
And they can all be
used for other things.
So we'll develop
some tools that will
help us to show, eventually
lead us to Freiman's theorem.
And I'll try to structure
this proof in such a way
that there are several
goal posts that
are also interesting.
So in particular, just as what
we did with Roth's theorem,
we'll begin by
proving a finite field
analog of Freiman's theorem.
So what would that mean,
a finite field analog?
So what would a problem like
this mean in F2 to the n?
So in F2 to the n, so this
is a finite field analog.
If A plus A is small--
so I'm not trying to
ask an inverse question.
But what are examples of
sets in F2 to the n that
have small doubling?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the n.
YUFEI ZHAO: So 2 to the n, so
you can take the entire space.
Any other examples that
have small doubling?
AUDIENCE: You can
take a subspace.
YUFEI ZHAO: Exactly,
I can take a subspace.
So a subspace, well,
it doesn't grow.
So A plus A is the same
as A. All right, so
and also, as before, you can
take a subset of a subspace.
So then the analog
of Freiman's theorem
will say that A is contained
in a subspace of size, at most,
a constant times the size of A.
So this is the analog of
Freiman's theorem in F2.
And so we'll see, so
this will be much easier
than the general result
about Freiman's theorem,
but it will involve
a subset of F2.
And we'll see this
theorem first.
So we'll prove
that next lecture.
Of course, this is much
easier in many ways,
because here, unlike
before, I don't even
have to think about
what subspace to take.
I can just take the subspace
generated by the elements of A.
All right, Any questions so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the f of k
here still exponential in k?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so the
question, is the f of k
here still exponential in k?
So the answer is, yes.
And the construction is if
you take A to be a basis.
OK, so let's start with some
techniques and some proofs.
So in this chapter, many
things are named after Ruzsa.
And at some point, it
becomes slightly confusing
which ones are not
named after Ruzsa.
But the first thing will
be named after Ruzsa.
So it's a Ruzsa
Triangle Inequality.
All right, the Ruzsa
Triangle Inequality
tells us that, if A, B, and C--
so unless otherwise
I tell you so,
and I'll try to remind you
each time, but basically,
we're always going to
be looking finite sets
in an arbitrary obedient group
always with an under addition--
then one has the inequality on
their sizes of different sets.
The size of A times
the size of B minus C
is upper bounded by the size of
A minus B times the size of A
minus C. So that's the
Ruzsa Triangle Inequality.
Let me show you the proof.
We will construct an injection
from A cross B minus C
to A minus B cross A
minus C. Of course,
if you can exhibit
such an injection,
then you prove the
desired inequality.
To obtain this injection, we
start with an element a, d.
And for this a, d, so
for each d, let me pick--
so if d is an
element of B minus C,
let us pick arbitrarily but
stick with those choices
a b of d in the set B and
a c of d in the set C such
that d equals to b
of d minus c of d.
So because d is
the set B minus C,
it can be represented as a
difference from one element
from each set.
So it may be represented
in many ways.
But from the start, you
pick a way to represent it.
And you stick with that choice.
And you label that
function b of d and c of d.
Now I map a, d to the element
a minus b of d and a minus
c of d.
So this is a map.
I want to show that
it is injective.
Why is it injective?
Well, to show
something is injective,
I just need to show that
I can recover where I came
from if I tell you the image.
So I can recover a and d
from these two numbers.
So if-- sorry, new board.
OK, so well you
basically can think
about how you can recover a
and d from the image elements.
So if the image--
so I label that map phi.
So that's phi up there.
So if the image is given,
then I can recover d.
So how can we recover
the element d?
So you subtract
these two numbers.
So d is minus x.
And once you recover d,
you can also then take
a look at the first element.
And you can recover a.
So now you know d.
I can now recover a.
OK, so then this is-- you can
check this is an injection.
And that proves the Ruzsa
Triangle Inequality.
OK, so it's short,
but it's tricky.
It's tricky.
OK, so why is this called
Ruzsa's Triangle Inequality?
Where is the triangle in this?
The reason that it's given
that name is that you can write
the inequality as follows.
Suppose we use rho A, B to
denote this quantity obtained
by taking the log of the
size of A minus B divided
by the square root
of the product
of their individual
sizes, then the inequality
says that the rho
of B, C is, at most,
rho of A, B plus rho of A, C,
which looks like a triangle
inequality.
So that's why it's called
Ruzsa's Triangle Inequality,
because this is--
don't take it too seriously,
because this is not a distance.
So rho of A, A is
not equal to 0.
But it certainly has the form
of a triangle inequality, hence
the name.
How should you think of
Ruzsa's triangle inequality?
So in this chapter,
there's going
to be a lot of symbol
pushing around.
And it's easy to get lost and
buried in all of these symbols.
And I want to tell
you about how you
might think about what's the
point of Ruzsa's Triangle
Inequality.
How would you use it?
And the idea is that if you
have a set with small doubling,
we want to use Ruzsa's
triangle inequality
and other tools to control
its further doublings.
So in particular, if--
so I'll say, applications.
So suppose you knew
that 2A minus 2A
is size, at most, k
times A. So this is
a stronger hypothesis than
just A has small doublings.
Even if you iterate
it several times,
you still have size, at
most, constant times A.
I would like to start
from this hypothesis
and control further
iterations, further subsets
of A. And Ruzsa's
Triangle Inequality
allows us to do it, because
by the Ruzsa's Triangle
Inequality, setting B
and C to be 2A minus A,
we find that 3A minus 3A is,
at most, 2A minus 2A squared
over A, the size of
A. So plug it in.
This is what you get.
So if the size of 2A plus 2A is,
at most, k times the size of A,
then the size of
3A times 3A is--
blows up by a factor,
at most, k squared.
So it controls
further doublings.
And of course, we can iterate.
If we know set B and
C to be 3A minus 2A,
then what we get is 5A
minus 5A is, at most,
a size of 3A minus 3A square
divided by the size of A.
And so now you have a bound
which is k to the 4 times A.
And you can continue.
You can continue.
OK, so this is all a
consequence of Ruzsa's triangle.
So starting with
this hypothesis,
now I get to control all
the further doublings,
the further subset iterations.
I call them doublings, but
they're no longer doubles,
but further subsets.
But this is a stronger
hypothesis than the one
that we start with
in Freiman's theorem,
because if you have that,
then this 2A minus 2A
is at least as large
as the size of 2A.
So can we start with
just doubling constant
and then obtain bounds
on the iterations?
| it turns out you can.
It will require another theorem.
So this theorem is called
Plunnecke inequality.
But actually, these
days, in literature,
it's often referred to as
Plunnecke-Ruzsa inequality.
So Plunnecke
initially proved it.
But nobody understood his proof.
And Ruzsa gave a better proof.
And actually, recently, there
was an even better proof.
And that's the one
I will show you.
So Plunnecke-Ruzsa
inequality tells us
that if A is subset of
some obedient group,
and has doubling
constant, at most, k,
then for all non-negative
integers m and n,
the size of mA minus
nA is, at most,
k to the m plus n
times the size of A.
So if you have bounded doubling,
then the further iterations,
the further subset iterations
are also controlling size.
I want you to think of
polynomial transformations in k
as negligible.
So don't worry about that
we're raising things here.
k is constant.
You should think of
m and n as constant.
So I'm changing k to
some other constant.
And in fact, I'm only
changing it by a polynomial.
So this is, like,
almost no change at all.
So this is tricky.
So we'll do it
after a short break.
All right, let's prove
Plunnecke's inequality,
Plunnecke-Ruzsa inequality.
So the history of
Plunnecke's inequality
has some similarities
with Freiman's theorem.
So Plunnecke
initially proved it,
but his proof was
hard to understand
and was sort of left not
understood for a long time
until others like
Plun and Ruzsa came in
and really simplified the proof.
But even then, the
proof was not so easy.
And if I were teaching this
course about 10 years ago,
I would have just skipped
this proof, maybe sketched
some ideas, but I would
have skipped the proof.
And the proof, actually,
it's a beautiful proof,
but it uses some
serious graph theory.
It uses Menger's
theorem about flows.
You construct some graph.
And then you try to
understand its flows.
It's very pretty stuff.
And I do encourage
you to look it up.
And then about eight
years ago, Petridis
found a proof, so a
proof by Petridis,
who was a PhD student that
Tim Gowers at the time.
And that was surprisingly
short, and beautiful,
and kind of surprised everyone
that such a short proof exists,
given that this theorem
sat in that state
for such a long time.
And it's a pretty
central step in the proof
of Freiman's theorem.
We'll prove Plunnecke-Ruzsa
via a slightly more general
statement.
So you see, it generalizes
the earlier statement.
Instead of having
one set, it will
be convenient to have
two different sets.
So let A and B be subsets of
some obedient group, as usual.
If size of A plus B is, at
most, k times the size of A,
then mB minus nB
has size, at most,
k to the m plus n
times the size of A
for all non-negative
integers m and n.
So instead of having one
set, so I have two sets,
A and B. Of course, then you
derive the earlier statement
setting A and B to equal.
So we'll prove this
more general statement.
The proof uses a key lemma.
And the key lemma says that if
a subset x of A is non-empty
and--
so if x is a
non-empty subset of A
that minimizes the ratio x
plus B divided by size of x,
and let k prime be this
ratio, this minimum ratio,
then so the conclusion
says that x plus B plus C
has size, at most, k prime times
the size of x plus C for all
sets C.
So that's the statement.
I'll explain how you should
think about the statement.
These ratios which you
see in both hypotheses,
how you should think about them
is that there is this graph.
Let's say it's the group
bipartite graph with the group
elements on both sides.
And the graph has edges,
the bipartite graph,
where the edges are from
each vertex a drawn edge
for each element of
B. So I expand by B.
So if you have
this graph and you
start with some A on the left,
then its neighbors on the right
will be A plus B. And
those ratios up there
are the expansion ratios.
so quantities like this,
they are expansion ratios.
You start with some
set on the left
and see by a what fraction
does it expand if you
look at the neighborhood.
So let's read the
statement of the key lemma.
It says, if you have a set x--
I look, so I have
a set A. And I'm
choosing a subset of A that
minimizes the expansion ratio,
so choose a
non-empty subset that
minimizes the expansion ratio.
And if this minimum expense
ratio is k prime, then,
so x minimizes expansion ratio
and expense ratios k prime,
then x plus C also has expansion
ratio, at most, k prime
as well.
So that's the statement.
I mentioned earlier that the
previous proofs of this theorem
went through some graph
theory and Menger's theorem,
that type of graph theory.
You can kind of see
where it might come in.
We're not going to do that.
We're going to stick with
additive combinatorics.
We're going to stick
with playing with sums,
playing with additive
combinatorics.
So let's see how we can
prove the statement up there,
so using the key lemma.
So assuming key lemma, so
let's prove the statement,
the theorem up there.
So take a non-empty
subset x of A--
sorry, so x subset of A that
minimizes the ratio x plus B
divided by x.
And let k prime be
this minimum ratio.
Note that k prime
is, at most, k,
because if you plug in x
equals the k, you get--
if you plug in x
equals to A, you get k.
But I'm choosing x to
be possibly even lower.
So k prime is, at most, k.
Now, applying the lemma, so
applying the key lemma with C
equals to B, we find that
x plus 2B, so C, plug in B,
x plus 2B has size, at most,
k times size of x plus B.
But the size of x plus B is,
at most, k times the size of A.
So we get k squared, so k
times the size of x, at most, k
squared x.
So we're already in good shape.
If you iterate
expansion twice-- so
I imagine there
is several chains
of these bipartite graphs.
If you iterate this
expansion twice,
you still do not
blow up by too much.
So we can iterate further,
so apply the lemma
with C being now 2B, and
then later 3B, and so on.
So you find that x
plus nB has size,
at most, k raised to power
n times the size of x
for all non-negative
integers, n.
What do we want to control?
So we want to prove a bound
on the size of mB minus nB.
Take a look at the statement
of Ruzsa Triangle Inequality.
Applying Ruzsa
Triangle Inequality,
we find that if we want
to control mB minus nB,
we can upper bound it by x
plus mB x plus nB divided
by the size of x.
Because each of these two
factors in the numerator
are small expansions
of x, now we
can upper bound the whole
expression by k to the m
plus n times the size of x.
And because x is a subset of A,
we can do one more upper bound
and obtain the bound
that we are looking for.
OK, so that proves
the key lemma.
It's OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry, that
proves the theorem,
assuming the key lemma.
Thank you, that's
what I meant to say.
Yeah, so that
proves the theorem,
assuming the key lemma.
So now we do prove
the key lemma.
Great, we need to
prove the key lemma.
And so Petridis' proof
of the key lemma,
it's quite surprising, in
that it uses induction.
And basically, we have
not used induction
in this course ever
since the first or maybe
the second lecture,
and for good reason.
So everything in this
course is fairly analytic.
You know, you have
these Roth bounds.
And putting one extra vertex
often doesn't really help.
OK, so here, we're going to use
induction on the size of C. OK,
I just want to emphasize again
that the use of induction
here was surprising.
So if the base case--
always check the base case--
when C is 1, then plus
C is a translation.
So this shifts the set over.
And so you can see that if
you do plus C and minus 1,
you raise the plus C. And the
conclusion follows basically
from the hypothesis.
So in this case,
x plus B plus C is
equal to x plus B, which is, at
most, k prime times the size x,
by definition of--
so this actually is
equal to the size of k.
The base case is easy.
Now we do the induction step.
So let's assume that the
size of C is bigger than 1
and C is C prime plus an
additional element, which
we'll call gamma.
So let's see this
expression, x plus B plus C,
by separating it according
to if its contribution came
from C prime or not.
The contributions that
came from C prime,
I can write it like that.
And then there are other
contributions, namely
those that came from
this extra element.
But I may have some
redundancies in doing this.
So I may have some redundancies
coming from the fact
that some of the
elements in this set
might have already
appeared earlier.
So let me take
out those elements
by taking out elements where
it already appeared earlier.
So this means I'm
looking at the set z
being elements of x such that
x plus B plus gamma is already
a subset of x plus
B plus C prime.
So the stuff in yellow,
I can safely discard,
because it already
appeared earlier.
So because of the
definition of z,
we see that z plus
B plus gamma appears
in x plus B plus C prime.
So that union is valid.
Now, z is a subset of x.
So the expansion ratio
for z is at least k prime,
because we chose x to
minimize this expansion ratio.
We would like to understand
how big x plus B plus C.
So let's evaluate the
cardinality of that expression
up there.
The cardinality
I can upper bound
by the union of these sum of
the sizes of the components.
So up there, so I just do a
union bound on that expression
up there.
And now you see z
is a subset of x.
So I can split this
expression up even further.
All right, now let's use
the induction hypothesis.
So we have some
expression involving
x plus B plus C prime.
So now we apply induction
hypothesis over here
to this expression
that has plus C prime.
And we obtain an
upper bound which
is k prime x plus C prime.
And the two expressions
on the right,
well, one of them here
is, by definition,
coming from the
expansion ratio of x.
And then the other, we
gave a bound just now.
OK, so we're almost there.
So we are trying to upper bound
the size of this quantity.
So we decomposed it into pieces
according to its contribution
coming from this extra element.
And we analyzed these
pieces individually.
But now I want to understand
the right-hand side,
so x plus C. So let's try to
understand the right-hand side.
See, the x plus C, I can
likewise write it as earlier
by decomposing it into
contributions from C prime
and those from
the extra element.
And as earlier, we can take out
contributions that were already
appearing earlier, which we
now recall W plus gamma, where
W is the set of elements in
x, such that x plus gamma
is already contained
in x plus C prime.
So this part was already
included earlier.
We don't need to
include it any more.
A couple of observations that
were different from earlier--
now this union I claim
and say disjoined union.
So this union is
a disjoined union.
So there is actually
no more overlaps.
And furthermore, W is contained
in the set z from earlier.
Any questions?
All right, therefore,
the size of x plus C
is equal to, because this
is a disjoined union, x
plus C prime plus the size
of x minus the size of W,
and which is--
so W, because W
is contained in z,
is x plus C prime plus the
size of x minus the size of z.
Now you compare these
two expressions.
And that proves the key lemma.
OK?
That's it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain one more time
why it's a disjoined union?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, great, so why
is this a disjoined union?
Now, I have the set here.
So I'm looking at
this x plus gamma.
So think about, let's
say, gamma equals to 0.
So we translate, think
about if gamma equals to 0.
So I include x, but if some
element of x was already here,
I take it out.
So here is x plus C prime.
And let's say this set is x.
This W then would there
be their intersection.
So now x minus W
is just this set.
So it's a disjoined union.
So the points are, here,
you're adding single elements,
where there, you're
adding some sets.
So you cannot necessarily take
a whole partition, necessarily.
But here it's OK.
It's tricky.
Yeah, it's tricky.
And you know, this took a
long time for people to find.
It was found about
eight years ago.
And yeah, it was surprising
when this proof was discovered.
People did not expect
that this proof existed.
And it's also
tricky to get right.
So the details-- I do it slowly.
But the execution,
like, the order
that you take the
minimalities is important.
It's easy to mess up this proof.
OK, any questions?
Let me show you, just as
an aside, an application
of this key lemma.
So earlier we saw Ruzsa's
Triangle Inequality.
And you may wonder, what if
you replace the minus signs
in the theorem by plus signs?
I mean, if you replace
the right-hand side,
the two pluses by minuses,
the same proof works.
But if you replace all the minus
signs by plus signs, you see,
the proof doesn't work anymore.
Just give yourself a moment
to convince yourself that.
If you just replace all the
minus signs by plus signs,
it doesn't work anymore,
but it's still true.
So this is more of an aside.
We will not use it.
But it's nice.
It's fun.
So we have the inequality A B
plus C bounded by A plus B A
plus C.
So hopefully you've
convince yourself
that if you follow our notes
with the previous proof,
you are you're not
going to get it.
You're not going to
prove this this way.
It's still true.
So how can we prove it?
So we are going to
use the key lemma.
So first, the statement
is trivial if A is empty.
So let's assume
that's not the case.
Let x be a subset
of A that minimizes
the expression or the
expansion ratio x plus B
divided by x as
in the key lemma.
So let k denote the
quantity A plus B over A,
so the expansion ratio
for A, and k prime
be the expansion ratio for x.
So the quantities
came up earlier.
k prime is, at most, value of
k, because of our choice of x.
So the key lemma
gives x B plus C--
OK, and this, it's really
amazing what's happening.
It seems like we're just going
to throw in some extra stuff.
So I'm going to upper
bound it by x plus B
plus C. I'm just going to
throw in some extra stuff.
And then by the lemma, I can
upper bound this expression
by k prime times the
size of x plus C.
So that's what the
lemma gives you.
And because x is
a subset of A, we
can upper bound it by the size
of A plus C. And now k prime
is, at most, the size of k.
k prime is, at most, k.
So you have that.
But now look at what
the definition of k is.
And that's it.
So that's how you
can prove this harder
version of Ruzsa's Triangle
Inequality, Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Are there
equality cases for this?
YUFEI ZHAO: All right,
question, are there
equality cases for this?
Yes, so I mean, if
you're in a subgroup,
then all things are
equal, although,
if A, B, and C are
all the same subgroup
of some finite obedient group.
AUDIENCE: What if you're
working in the integers?
YUFEI ZHAO: Great,
yeah, so the question
is, what if you're
working in integers?
That's a good question.
I mean, you can suddenly
get expansion ratio of two
if you have--
no, OK.
Right, yeah, so that's
a good question.
Can you get equality cases?
If you set A, B, and C to be
sets of very different sizes,
AP is a very different set.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you set B being
true for the single element
and B and C to just be sets
that have full extension
so that B plus C is not [? B. ?]
YUFEI ZHAO: Great,
yeah, so you take
A to be a
single-element set, then
it could be that B plus C
is the same as the size of B
times the size of C if B and C
have no additive interactions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there
other known proofs
of this that are less involved?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, are there
other known proofs of this?
I don't know.
I'm not aware of other proofs.
It would be nice to
find a different proof.
More questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How did
come up with this?
YUFEI ZHAO: How did
he come up with this?
You know, Petridis
did a very long PhD.
He spent, I think, seven
or eight years in his PhD.
And he eventually came
up with this proof.
So he must have thought
a lot about this problem.
But the already
proofs are still nice.
The earlier proofs, I think
they are worth looking at.
They are looking at
expansion ratios in graphs.
So you take a sequence of
graphs, multi-partite graphs.
And you think about expansion.
And you think about flows.
It's, again, not easy at
all, but maybe more motivated
if you're used to think about
expansions and flows in graphs.
And this one really distills
the core ideas of that proof,
but looks something you can
teach in half a lecture,
whereas before this
proof came about,
I could have taught the
proof, but most likely,
I would have just skipped it.
To just give you a sense of
what's coming up ahead, so
going forward, the first thing
we'll do in the next lecture
is we'll show--
we'll see the proof of
the Freiman's theorem
in the finite field
setting, so in F2 to the n.
There is one more thing, one
more very quick lemma called
the covering lemma,
Ruzsa are Covering Lemma,
that I will tell you.
And then once we
have that, then we
can prove Freiman's theorem
in the finite field setting.
But then moving on
to the integers,
we'll need to understand how
to think about the integers.
Well, if you start with a
subset of integers, they could,
even if you have a small
number of elements,
they could be spread out,
really, all over the place.
But because you only care
about the additive structure
within the integers,
you can try to model
that very spread-out
set of integers
to something that
is very compact.
So there is something
called the modeling
lemma, Ruzsa's Modeling Lemma,
that we'll see next time.
And that will play a
pretty important role.
Before finishing
off, I also want
to mention that Freiman in his
work, so he had this result.
And he also wrote a book I think
called The Structural Theory
of Set Addition, or
something like that, that
emphasized this connection.
He tried to draw this
analogy sort of comparing
additive combinatorics to
geometry in the sense of cline,
where in order to
understand sets,
you don't think about sets.
You think about
maps between sets,
which was kind of an
obscure idea at the time.
But we'll see next
lecture that this actually
is a very powerful, it's
a very influential idea
to really think about
a sets of integers
under transformations
that only preserve
their additive structure.
So we'll see this next time.